وفي العربيه هناك من زملائنا من عاش لحظات
انطلاقه واستمر معها حتى الان زميلتنا
العزيزه ميسون عزام من اقدم الموظفين في
العربيه وصديقه دائما لصباح العربيه
حتى انها شاركت البرنامج فتره حملها
بابنتها جنى تحيه لجنى جنى الان اصبحت
شابه وهي ايضا شاركتنا في صباح العربيه
برساله انسانيه لمرضى السرطان عندما كانت
في العاشره من عمرها نشوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بدايه حديثي عن تجربه الحمل مش راح تكون
بس عن المراحل اللي بتمر فيها اي امراه
حامل ولكن راح احكي معكم بلسان المراه
العامله الحامل وطبعا بوضعي المذيع الحامل
مش راح اقول انه شغلنا اصعب شغل بالعالم
اكيد كل موظفه بتتعرض لضغوط خلال عملها بس
هذا ما بيمنع ابدا انه المذيعات بصوره
عامه وبالايام العاديه بتعرضوا للكثير من
الضغوط هذا بالايام العاديه فما بالكم لما
تكون المذيعه حامل
[موسيقى]
طبعا شغلنا بيبدا قبل ما نطلع على الهواء
اول شيء لازم نمر بغرفه المكياج واللي
كانت لالي كابوس حقيقي خاصه بالاشهر
الاولى من حملي
[موسيقى]
رح تنضم الينا في الاستوديو الطفله جنى
ابو ورده اللي قررت طبعا انه تتبرع بشعرها
على الهواء مباشره
ستشاركنا هذه التجربه صباح الخير يا جنى
طبعا جنى كم عمرك عشره عشره ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
طبعا انتم ما تتخيلوا كم الناس الموجودين
في الاستوديو اللي بتابعوا هذه اللحظه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا الشرح الاعلامي الكبير كيف كان شعورك
وقتها
لا جميل جدا طبعا كان الثقل الجميل هو انه
هي امتداد لل ام بي سي وشغله ثانيه انه
احنا عم نحكي عن محطات
لهذه المؤسسه اللي هي مؤثره وجزء منها
الام بي سي ما فعلته وايضا جزء منها
العربيه ومن خلال يوميات ميسون اكيد رح
نحكي كتير عن هذا الموضوع بس كمان بدنا
نرحب بوحيد المصري زميلنا في قسم الرياضه
واذا ما تحدثنا عن الرياضه فان العربيه
تنفرد في قسم الرياضه وانتم الاساس يا
وحيد انت والزملاء بالتاكيد اليوم اذا
بدنا نحكي عن رياضه في عشرين عاما كيف
كانت وما الذي تغير حتى اليوم طبعا انا
سعيد اني موجود في عيد العربيه العشرين
كانه الامس كانه الامس اول يوم دخلت في
هذا المبلغ في صيف 2002 فتره الاعداد
الانطلاق القناه اللي بدات بثلاثه 2003
يعني مرت عشرين سنه كانها 90 دقيقه في
مباراه كره قدم
ليس اكثر
متقدمين متقدمين لحد الان طبعا هو الشعور
مختلف لما تكون في قسم الرياضه مع كل
الاحترام لكل الاقسام الاخرى لانه احنا
كقسم رياضه نعتبر نفسنا مصدر البهجه للاسف
اخبار السياسه دائما حروب اخبار الاقتصاد
اسهم بتطلع وتنزل وازمات اقتصاديه بتيجي
الناس عند الرياضه تشعر بالاستمتاع
والفرحه الرياضه بما لا تنجح به السياسه
دائما بنجمع العالم طيب هذا اللي شاهدناه
في كاس العالم الاخيره وحيد يتميز فيه قسم
رياضه خلال 20 عام هو التفرد والتميز
بالاخبار الحصريه لكره القدم ولكل اخبار
الرياضه الى كان تحدي للقسم طبعا التحدي
تختلف لانه الادوات اختلفت عندما بدانا
بال 2002 و2003 الانطلاقه ما كان في تويتر
ما كان في فيسبوك ما كان في يوتيوب ما كان
في كل هذه الادوات اللي موجوده المعلومه
كانت نادره الان التح هو وفره المعلومه
والقدره على فرز الصحيح الغث من السمين
منها يعني التحدي كان سابقا كيف تحصل على
المعلومه التحدي الان كيف تقدم المعلومه
ان تعرف اكثر بعيدا عن الاشاعات والاخبار
الكاذبه اللي يتلقاها اي شخص ووحيد
بالحديث عن التطورات التي طرات على
الاعلام ودخلنا على فكره نيو ميديا وهيك
زميلتنا ميسون عزام هي من اكثر الزميلات
نشاطا على السوشيال ميديا وبنلاحظ انه نعم
لميزك ست مدين بس عم بحكي انه من ناحيه
المحتوى وطريقه الطرح قديه مهم فعلا
مواكبه التطورات والتغيرات ميسون لانه
بلاحظ انه انت قدرت توصفي كمان السوشيال
ميديا بنفس وتيره ما توظفوا الشاشه كمان
وظهورك عليها هو اعتقد هذا جزء من المنصه
اللي اعطتنا اياه للعربيه
وخروجنا على النص انا هذا بقوله احنا لا
نتمرد على الاخبار ولا نتمرد على الواقع
الموجود ولكن نخرج
عن النص لنضيف نعطي اضافات يوميات ميسون
اسمحي لي انه اعود لالها عطشتني
بالبدايه
يوميات ميسون انا بعتبر انه هي جزء منها
من الخروج على النص للتاثير على الشارع
وهاي تتعلق تحديدا في قضيه تغيير النظره
المجتمعيه للمذيع الاخبار احنا جينا
العربيه بفتره كانت جامده جدا
فهزينا هاي الفتره
كان في صوت واحد صار في اكثر من صوت وبنفس
الوقت سبقنا كل شيء من خلال والنظره طبعا
المستقبليه استاذ عبد الرحمن الراشد كان
يعرف اين
المتابع يمكن له ان يتاثر ويتفاعل قبل
السوشيال ميديا احنا كنا موجودين وكان في
رؤيه ونظره كمان دائما مستقبلين احنا
بنشكركم جزيل الشكر وبس كمان انا دائما
قبل ما يصير عندي اولاد كانوا دائما
يقولوا لي شوفي ميسون عزام بتعاملها مع
اطفالها واولادها بصير طفله معهم وهيك
واكيد كان فعلا فيديو مؤثر اللي شفناه
كانه هل 17 سنه كانوا سبع ثواني
تحيات عمر بسرعه شكرا جزيلا ميسون شكرا
وحيد نورتونا في عيد العربي شكرا